more importantly when I come back in
September we're going to come with some
real fire on YouTube so you do get ready
I'm going to spend this time in a team
innocents time to really come back with
the 4.0 version of what we're doing here
me and Gary be up in the office you have
got a wilted record we talked about
ownership and leverage taking her
detectives out there beverage
[Music]
it's very simple at its most binary and
actually realize that you're a media
company and then you do whatever you do
well then everything else for me it's
about being able to stay alive to make
your media pure so that you can
capitalize on the back end because you
have a much bigger audience you know
people are selling programs on Instagram
and YouTube they're not on the cover of
Forbes they're not on CNN these things
matter brand brand is the single reason
that I'll be the guy of this era and it
will be the thing that I push you
towards this entire time all the things
I preach patience it takes time to build
a brand but it's the brand part that
will matter and it's understanding the
following you will never trick the
market let me ask you how many people in
the course of your days you're providing
content will ultimately bring that to
the web for you my team now yeah fifteen
fifty but here's the good news
twenty four months ago one one thing
that we've all stepped into [ __ ] in is
every nine-year-old can do it all so
there's literally to 24 year olds right
now who don't get to do what they want
to do these kids believe and especially
it's one thing about what she does and
what I do that's different that's
traditional but the actual creation
distribution and editing nine out of ten
times the 23 year olds veteran 34 year
old because they're more native and have
like Irish how long have you been doing
your thing with video right you know
like VidCon was like who is or the
writer you know I mean like like there's
people who've been doing it since they
were 9 I be editing and production and
engineering and creation far more like
the NBA where like if you're good enough
at 18 you're just good enough it's a
talent I prefer you hire it as your
overhead because my intuition is you'll
be more successful you're a place on on
the Internet the foreigners you don't
know where a person is publish the
equivalent of an episodic reality show I
thought that's really existing I do
suicide and I do I devote 30 minutes to
have you ever seen daily be yes that's
what I do that's what this is right now
right
it's called Facebook and YouTube you're
on it listen I'm only in a different
because I did exactly what you just said
instead of begging Netflix and Hulu and
Amazon and ABC I just went to the
consumer at scale
it's called Facebook in YouTube man
Apple came to me to do it the right way
it's all marathon to do it the wrong way
it's sprint and that's why you know if
you can leave here with knowing that
you're a media company and your behavior
should map towards it and you separate
and don't have pregnant the sales and
branding you can create that environment
then you've got something shoot for the
moon because if you land at the clouds
cool like like you know like if you
shoot for the cloud you're gonna be on
top of a tree thanks right see you guys
later enjoy
the Foods of the day like of the last
week really impacts all of us actually
we're all here we have to get out of the
business of having brains doing blonde
listen I'm going to say something right
now I'm going away for three weeks I've
been on fire for the last two months
like you got a lot to do but like can
please can be like like Tyler I don't
give a [ __ ] like watch it well that's
why it's going to be good so our next
three weeks is basically we're doing
this jvv season thing so next week is
season 1 recap which is like one through
91 which Ellie are you went all the way
through there's not going to be as much
gold there but we're going to replay it
out see halfway through season two and
all of season three has never even been
looked at and how big a difficulty this
whole time always with the big stuff
like two years but I don't know what I
don't know and I'll just keep going
versus like having these people have
access to this footage the other thing
is we can make so much gold like do you
know cool beef for me just like I want
to make some haha throwaway content like
seven and a half hours of meeting
selfies like I like hacking culture like
let's put up a seven and a half hour
video seven half hours with every song
we've ever used on daily be of me just
taking selfies like and like I don't
care if anybody watches that like nobody
wants to watch that I just wanted to
exist like things like that where it's
more like just branding haha like
packing he was like that what I just
said was super good and what has to be
our culture okay so there's that Eric
hates it whatever but here's but here's
what's funny me even thinking irritates
it makes me then react so then I go ten
okay how do I make this more valuable
aha I'm going to get HarperCollins to
release the audio of the Thank You
economy for free and I'm going to put it
on the back of seven a half hours of
[ __ ] me taking selfies and now I'm
like hey gang the Thank You economy
audio
free here it is link oh by the way I put
seven hours of you taking selfies with
you guys on it thank you you know like
got it
good idea there it is that's how I
brainstorm everyone I didn't take
vacations when you and I knew each other
there's a very funny papers there's very
funny things that
and when I go on vacation yes a lot more
I'll talk to guys I will literally talk
to you more very odd the first thing
this week with my parents but at home
you will hear from me like 80 you see
you see I talked to you on a weekend
like it's about to get real serious up
in here go in a different world I would
probably be an all-time debate champion
oh yeah difficulty enough we hear their
encounter I'm like karate I like let
their force make them walk into
heading down to Long Island City YouTube
this is going to be your first look we
build a huge studio in Long Island City
for all the production capabilities we
want for video and audio where we will
do our original podcast series that
we're going to continue to make the
clients and ourselves when we're doing
all sorts of Facebook commercials for
our clients I'm going to try to hack it
obviously a lot of times when I'm going
to airports it's better for me to be
there so rare footage of me in the
subway
subway life iris cloudy
[Music]
how's it goin learning Laxus what are
the most unusual things like how is it
different with me five minutes
meaning the backpack yes and energy so
man so brother how are you know what I
love it because they're you know
although they just look oh my god
right and I like the engine that you buy
good positive everything honey / vinegar
yeah put you down if you put your Duncan
so I'm excited
hey hey
[Music]
thug life is good boys very nice and
welcoming one like big question I have
it's kind of like it's almost like
forums which on spot though I'm
comfortable in the space a major sports
even about like collective conscience
this is not it's about it like
completely full service like and on to
being true yes like to do that you want
me to like blow out the client to staff
ratio that's like currently in place
like come into space like what you're
trying to grow that debt like how are
you going to get around by not by not
caring about how much money we make so
it's that extra long time that's like
that's like over song a little Tyler
like it like right now yeah guys will
leave to go this is a chance to see the
cars but if they're really thinking like
what's this for me yeah you know you
guys know this was consuming whatever
level of content you consumed with me
like I'm given people the blueprint I
just don't think they have the skills to
execute it I'm showing people what to do
how to think about it what works
people aren't built for it alpha male 22
years old
hey bro each [ __ ] for a decade and don't
enjoy all the alpha bro things that come
along with being an alpha male from 22
to 32 money dude signing up I don't
think people understand what we're about
to do in that world yeah you get to see
it firsthand you'll do just like the
people that were at being or seven years
ago be like oh we were in means like
when you're in a big nice fancy banner
sports office you know maybe like no no
we started in vaynermedia like people
didn't even know we would slap my iris
you know you know what I mean like
bumpers the bench yes yes and then now
they have pink Manning and Tom Brady and
Michael Jordan right like that's what's
gonna happen
it's a foregone conclusion as long as AJ
and I stay healthy like just what's
going
happen it's because of the balance
between the talent and the patience if
you're actually great and you're
actually patient you become
fundamentally unbeatable did you see
that moment and you I'm sure you guys
watch the USC talk right the best moment
I'll talk is when I'm like this is the
best most of you can ever have it
gratitude
it's just gratitude like one life one
at-bat one time I just don't want to see
that regret in my eyes that I see in so
many and that's why it's so fun for me
to come and talk to you now because like
straight up for 90% of you this is the
greatest year of your life right now
that's just the truth it could be mad at
me can be sad at me you can think I'm
stupid telling you straight to your
[ __ ] faces for 80 to 90% of you this
is it this is the [ __ ] pinnacle so
you better squeeze the [ __ ] out of this
thing because if you're smart and you do
then it won't be that was such a [ __ ]
you moment the air left yeah laughs hey
like you're right okay what do they
think I'm right or they thought [ __ ] you
like I'm still gonna be right but it's
all about the kid yeah it's all about
the CEO it's all about the quarterback
it's about saying yes for everybody and
accepting no from everybody yeah that's
a good spot
I just think everybody's gonna say yes
why I pitched them something but I'm
super cool when ninety percent say now
and I make my bread on the phantom it's
a yes and then I stick it to the people
that's a no I'll never be too fancy yeah
I just can't
it's not in me I can't fell out it's
just not in me are you saying it goes
back to just the balance of the job
Bevers of the horse and so it like
you're gonna go is this earrings oh I'm
going to go for look one thing I will
tell you is if two monix I've been three
years from now the number one rated
quarterback is begging me to take him
and he's a douche bag we're not taking
them so there's that on the flip side if
I fall in love with a punter in nine
years we'll go
so it's got it yeah it's more about the
human another agent are you gonna be
looking for at Vayner sport saying hi I
don't know I don't know I don't know
enough yet I'm still tasting I'll be
able to really answer that in two or
three years just not yet know what kind
of quality if you think that that a site
we've that they need to look at me and
AJ they need to be a [ __ ] stole call
assassin but a good human being like
just cuz she can close everybody doesn't
mean she could be a douchebag to
everybody
do you think you know I mean yeah just
got to be straight up [ __ ] with like
the best winner
what's that means natural a lot no a lot
like the I guess they're not that a good
person box like that charisma starts
charisma super hard to create you know
to be binary early as an assassin is
teachable ish
I see the confidence and the people
around me grow but not to become me so
like I think of it like basketball let's
actually football but let's use
basketball because it's a little bit
different I think all three of us all
four of us can be better basketball
players and I don't think we can be
LeBron like I think if I play basketball
five hours a day starting tomorrow at 41
years old every day that in two years I
can really play I think my left will
fully developed I think you know I think
I'll be really good and a lot
I think the key for you guys all three
of you at this young age just to figure
out what were the things that were given
and make them better
so if you're kind become the most kind
person of all time
betting on strengths obsessed obsessed
with that thesis so like okay cool
YouTube go get more charismatic like me
you're not going to do it but if you are
the [ __ ] triple down on that but
don't be full of [ __ ] and use your
charisma as a negative take care
[ __ ] soon there for some reason right
such a pleasure but you're mine you know
I mean it because I think I think I
think of an all-time unique person I
genuinely believe that and honestly I
think I used to think it for different
reasons than I do now now I really
[ __ ] believe it you know
I think I before intuitively thought
maybe yeah now it's [ __ ] obvious yeah
alright so drew first of all I created
like produced a bunch of like really
[ __ ] dope music that I'm sure you
would buy about he listened to the [ __ ]
like this production valued love is with
all these West Coast ours that we passed
with so now he has like my favor like
hip-hop clothing grant he's just
murdering it it's right here for you the
shorties and Lincoln influence are with
him until he died almost like the
influencer yeah you know of course of
course
so what things are happening you don't
copy tracking me I get it come about you
where would you grow up what do you
think what is the 21 year old you think
yeah yeah that's a good night I know I
did
how do you know look good then that good
DNA just in the right mix I understand
about HR like what are you trying to do
the angle is just have more like a long
dead no it has longevity is going to
come at the variable of how good you are
at continuing to do what you're doing
everybody starts off looking like you
and then they sell out and then the
streets don't [ __ ] with them yeah you
know that I don't explain it so so the
good news is I don't think influencers
are the vulnerability of long [ __ ] like
what no I know
you know I everything I've heard I know
you I'm just repeating [ __ ] you know
it's just attention the key is do you
it's my story the reason I'm never
scared is I'm not going to sell out I'm
never going to think I'm better than
anybody thus in the business world
that's the sellout yeah let's get to
know each other real pleasure yeah keep
doing your thing man I will yeah cool so
here's what I would say how old are you
quick you should 100% go in the family
but yeah let me tell you why
and never regret it okay you don't know
how long your mom and everybody else
gonna be on art yeah you will never
regret going into the family business
you may completely waste three years of
your life it's just not that much time
okay thank you Gary hey guys before it
goes back into the city out here in Long
Island's video it's been amazing before
I go back in the city there's a little
bit of my sign off as you might have saw
in the article I wrote let's put the URL
here let's create a little mini URL
let's link it in the episode here on
YouTube I'm going off the grid with
family now for the rest of August right
up until Labor Day I'm gonna you know
attack it from the August strategy that
I have this has been an incredible
journey with you guys so far is the
biggest break I'm taking since I've been
kind of all out of my blog I just want
to thank you for that and more
importantly when I come back in
September we're going to come with some
real fire on YouTube so you do get ready
I'm just going to time me in the team
names from this time to really come back
with the 4.0 version of what we're doing
here
you